My name's Aditya.
This talk is entitled koro, translating human
code back into languages and back again.
I've been writing JavaScript off and on again
for about 20 years, but these days my primary
language isn't JavaScript, it's Go.
I've been writing Go for the last seven years
and I will be taking a look at work that has
been done?
Go and seeing how we might apply that same
work to the JavaScript world as well.
Even though my examples will be in Go, everything
can and should be done in JavaScript too.
How many of you speak English as a second
language?
That's the overall majority here.
So worldwide, only five per cent of the world
speaks English as their first language, and
only about 11 per cent speaks English at all.
That means that the majority of people who
speak English speak it as their second language.
If this conference were perfectly represented
of the entire world, that only means 165 people
out of this entire conference would be able
to understand this talk, and of those, all
but 75 would be listening to me speak in what
is for them a foreign language.
I feel like to say software is eating the
world, but also JavaScript is eating software.
I don't just mean that things are moving to
the web, which has always been JavaScript's
platform of dominance, but JavaScript also
is being used in ways that we never really
thought of maybe like 20 years ago.
Node.js was launched on this very stage ten
years ago at this conference, and that completely
changed the way in which we think of JavaScript.
JavaScript is now being used - you can use
JavaScript to write Excel macros.
Try explaining someone to that in the mid-90s,
that you would be using live script to write
your Microsoft Office macros.
If you want to do positioning logic within
Linux, you're going to be writing JavaScript
rules.
Technology which includes software is a powerful
enabling force.
We have the ability to do amazingly things
on a global scale using software.
Thanks to software, we are able to take pictures
of a black hole that is 55 million light years
away.
We can treat and cure diseases that would
have been thought chronic or even fatal just
a few decades ago.
We might not think of this as achievements
of software specifically but software is the
underlying force that is powering and enabling
all of these.
But software can be used for terrible things
as well, using it to inflict violence or commit
genocide.
If we think software is a powerful and enable
enabling force, who does it enable and what
does it allow them to do?
I have really lives who don't speak English.
If one came to me and said they want to learn
to write software and asked me for advice,
the first thing I would say is you have to
learn English because if you don't speak English,
you're not really going to be able to do much
in the software world, certainly not in open-source
software development.
Especially if you don't even read the Latin
script because your native language uses a
different script altogether.
That itself is a barrier.
If writing software is only an option for
the ten per cent of the world who can speak
English, that has huge implications about
what it means when we say that software is
an empowering and enabling force.
So if JavaScript wants to be the future of
software development and we think that software
development is going to be an enable willing
force for the world, then we need to writing
JavaScript is accessible to people of all
languages, not just English.
The idea of eliminating natural language barriers
to programming isn't new at all.
In fact, it's very old.
Grace Hopper is one of the first computer
scientists and she wrote THE very first compiler
for a high-level language.
You should check out her portrait there.
The language that she invented was called
Cobal, and the goal was to have English-like
national language syntax so that business
executives could write code.
She got a lot of pushback about this because
engineers thought if non-engineers can write
code, this can put us out of a job but Hopper
took this vision further.
Why restrict it to English-like syntax?
What if engineers who speak other languages
want to be able to write code as well, and
she wanted Cobal to be a language you can
talk to people around the world.
The response she got to that was more vitriolic.
How can we teach American computers to run
German programmes?
That wasn't an accident.
This wasn't a question of how it can be done
technically, it was a political question.
This was the 1950s, and in the US military,
the fear of a threat from Germany or Russia
was still a huge fear in people's minds.
But even if Hopper's idea was put on the back
burner in the 1950s due to xenophobia and
Cold War politics, we can look at what that
means today, and apply that approach to modern
languages.
So this is Hopper speaking about Cobal many
years later, ""I would have thought it would
be useful to NATO because they had the common
verbs for the things they're going to do,
and the nouns, they have to have a dictionary
for the things they were referring to for
inventory control.
They would have common announce throughout
NATO and a diction of common verbs and translate
the programme.
You can write one in English and you could
translate it and it goes to the other language.
No problem.
You have communication.
It would be a limited vocabulary.""
One thing is that she chose the imperative
mood specifically because she thought it would
be universal to languages, because not all
languages distinguish between tenses in the
same way but they generally have a commanding
way to do something.
Cobol popularised the programming style, and
that stuck with us today.
Even JavaScript, way has the capabilities
of a function al language, we still usually
use imperatives for the four function names
and that is - let's see what we get when we
take the principles of hopper's vision and
apply that to a modern programming language
like JavaScript or Go, Koro is an extension
of the Go compiler.
It's an idiomatic translation of the English
name Go.
You will see why I chose it for this example.
But as for Bengali, I chose that because Bengali
it's the language my family speaks, and we're
Bengali, and, if you talk to Bengali about
our language and culture, you'll see very
quickly that we're pretty proud of it.
The Bengalis like to say is the language that
is so beautiful, people literally fought a
revolution, an entire war, to defend the right
to speak it.
The United Nations more recently actually
issued a declaration stating that Bengali
was the sweetest-sounding language in the
entire world.
But on a more practical note, Bengali is a
pretty common language.
After Hindi, it's the most common language
spoken in India, and also the national language
of Bangladesh.
Combined, that means it's the seventh most
widely spoken language in the entire world.
There are more native speakers of Bengali
than there are of German and French combined.
It also uses a non-Latin script, so it gives
us an opportunity to test the boundaries of
what we can do with Unicode and how characters
get treated and rendered in languages outside
the ASCII code range.
Again, nothing that I'm doing here is unique
to Bengali or to Go.
If you speak another language, which it seems
the majority of this room does, I encourage
you to go home and try to do this with your
own language as well.
This right here is a simple ""hello, world""
in standard Go.
If you've never written a line of code, you
can guess what it is doing here.
This is that equivalent programme written
in koro.
We've left the identifier names intact, and
I did not forget ""true"", true is not a key
word in Go.
Based on the previous slide, you can take
a guess at what this programme is doing.
If you don't speak Bengali, you might not
be able to figure it out from scratch, if
you do, this is a whole lot more readable
than what we just saw on the previous slide.
The first challenge we need to do here is
we need to get this programme to run because
the Go compiler isn't going to know what to
do with the key words.
Here we can take advantage of a nice trick.
This is why we chose Go for this example.
Go's source code is all UTF8.
The Go compiler has trouble dealing with non-ASCII
characters in Go programmes and the Go compiler
is bootstrapped, written in Go which means
that the Go compiler is a Go programme so
it has trouble dealing with non-ASCII key
word definitions or strings.
There are a few checks that ensure that non-alphabetic
or non-alphabetic characters can be used in
key words but it turns out that you additional
them and nothing goes wrong.
If we disable them, all you need to do is
extend the mapping that has the strings, that
map strings to the internal tokens, and extend
those to include the Bengali translations
of the key words as well.
JavaScript already has the analogous concept
of transformations, and that is something
that is used heavily in JavaScript, if languages
like TypeScript and also with polyfills, and
it is a little trickier to do this for reasons
of they have to do with compiler architecture
which I'm not going to get into, but it's
still - it's fairly similar.
It's the still very much possible to use this
same approach in JavaScript to translate from
one human language to another, or one dialect
of a programming language to another.
Having made those changes, this is what that
""Hello, World"" looks like in practice.
You can see the programme, and we are going
to run it.
There we go.
Thank you.
[Applause].
Remember, our goal is to defragment open-source
development, not to fragment it further.
We need to make sure that our code that we
are writing in koro is still interoperable
with English-speaking Go developers are use
as well.
We don't want to have to translate every programme
manually because that would be unfeasible,
but the computers are doing the heavy-lifting
for us.
Conveniently, for translation, Go has a handy
utility for format ing - and mostly we you
have the use Go format to argue over bike
shedding, semicolons, things like that.
Instead of arguing which is the proper way
to indent your code, you set up the editor
whichever way you want and render tabs how
you want them to be, and, when you save your
code, it's committed in the standard form.
If I want to use four spaces for indentation
and you want to use two, Go format means we
can work together.
I set up my editor to render it to the width
I want and we don't need to know that we have
different indentation preferences because
the code committed is on the standard form.
Go format is syntax aware, so it can do things
like remove unnecessarily parentheses and
ensure it will never change your code semantics.
That's a simpler way of saying it is a great
way of performing fully isomorphic translations
of source code which is exactly what we could
wouldn't here.
All we have to do is extend Go format and
repurpose it for translating English Go code
into Bengali or vice versa, and that is what
koro format does.
So let's translate that same programme written
in koro back into English-speaking Go and
run it.
Here is the koro programme.
And now we can format it, and we get the English
programme again, but if you don't believe
me, we can run it and prove it does the exact
same thing.
There we go.
We just translated from one language to another,
and back again.
There we go.
So the same way that you didn't know that
I was using four spaces for tabs and I don't
know that you were using two, having bidirectional
translation layers means you don't need to
know that I'm writing my code in English and
I don't need to know that you're writing your
code in whatever language you happy to speak.
We can still work together and we localise
our source code as a commit hook and the editor
will display it for us in the language that
we want.
As a developer, koro means we only need to
look at source code in our own language, and
as far as the code is concerned, the language
barriers are no more of a barrier to you and
me writing code and working together than
our indentation preferences are.
That's the way it should be.
Translated the key words but you will notice
that we left the - we didn't touch everything,
so like the package names and identifiers,
those we kept in English.
Is there a way that we can translate those
as well in there are a lot of ways to choose
variable names but the one thing that everyone
agrees on is they should be descriptive and
concise.
If you don't speak English, then it's not
descriptive to have English codenames.
In reality, many functional names are highly
structured.
We don't need to, as Hopper mentioned, we
already have the verbs that we use when talking
about our programme.
There is the common vocabulary.
We can take advantage of that in the translation
step as well and translate these.
There we go.
So, yes, we have read fu, write fu, et cetera,
and these are common verbs that you use when
we write JavaScript programming, and even
if we don't translate all of them, having
that on the right is a whole lot better and
descriptive and compatible on the rest.
You might know what fu means, you might not
be able to pronounce that, but you can still
tell that that means you're going to be reading
something.
It's some sort of access or method.
By being more conscious about these conventions
we're already using, we can make our code
that much more accessible to non-English speakers.
We might not get all of these translations
for free but we can still get many of them,
and that is a huge step forward.
Now the million-dollar question: could we
do this with JavaScript?
There are a few reasons I chose Go for this
example.
In Go the source code is acquired by the UTF8
means internally strings and byte arrays are
treated as UTF8 as well.
JavaScript is - source code can be what you
want in JavaScript, whatever the interpreter
happens to support.
As for the internal representation of strings,
that is an even trickier question.
If you talk to most people, they will say
UTF-16, wide Unicode, that's mostly true except
where it's not.
Some people will say it's UCS2, that some
were true except where it's not.
The reality is probably best described like
this like this: JavaScript is some weird amalgamation
of UTF16 and UTFC2 internally which works
fine, but it makes, trickier when you're dealing
with non-ASCII things outside the code point,
especially when you're dealing with the actual
digging into the actual internals of the language
implementation itself because you can't rely
on the source encoding, because it can be
whatever the interpreter happens to support,
and you can't rely on, and dealing with code
points that are far outside the ASCII code
range so you need to be able to handle more
than one byte at a time in your key words.
A lot of implementations, particularly things
implemented in C, they're going to struggle
with that.
Could we do this in JavaScript?
I mean, honestly, I think so.
Definitely, not as easy as it is in Go, like
I've outlined some of the challenges there,
but definitely possible.
That said, one of my friend, who is a very
die-hard JavaScript programmer, she told me
that the best way to get JavaScript developers
to write something is to convince them that
it can't be done in JavaScript.
If you tell them they can't tell them in JavaScript,
then within an hour of your talk finishing,
there will be three packages which do that
thing.
I'm going to tell you this can't be done in
JavaScript, and I'm going to bet that you
cannot prove me wrong!
[Applause].
Ask how we've done the - we've done the source
code itself, and we have to talk about the
users, and the users include developers who
are using developer tooling as well.
Error messages are a big part of that.
Node.js does a pretty good job with this by
abstracting the way that messages are presented
from the internals of it, so JavaScript actually
already does, I would say, well, some platforms
of JavaScript, does maybe 70 per cent of the
work that you would need for this.
Go is an approach to error-handling that is
different from most languages, but if you've
actually written JavaScript, you're probably
still familiar with it, because in JavaScript,
you can't use access - exception handling
to, or error handling within a callback because
it's asynchronous code.
You have to pass in error values and operate
on the values.
Go does the exact same thing but for all code
where synchronous or asynchronous.
In Go, to juice JavaScript terminology, all
errors are an object that happens for a dot
error method on it, and that is guaranteed
to return a string.
That's the only thing that you're guaranteed
to know about than error is that one specific
method is present and it will always return
a string if it is not null.
And that applies, that is a proper that means
it's powerful but it means that that message
then needs to be accessible to people who
don't speak English because - what happened
here?
As developers, we've struggled with cryptic
error messages.
This is from Java because I've been using
it so long as an example of a terrible error
message that I've forgotten what it means.
It's a real error message.
If you know what it means, tell me, because
it's been years, I've forget.
JavaScript isn't immune, either.
If you write JavaScript a lot, you probably
have an idea of what that means and what the
error is, but if you've never written JavaScript,
this is your first time encountering that
error, it's not so clear what you need to
do there to fix it.
Certainly if you don't speak English because
the only thing that is worse than a cryptic
error message is a cryptic error message in
a language you can't understand.
Translating error messages is a good starting
point.
Not only are they fine night in full - finite
in number - and they are the easiest to solve
technically because we can rely on existing
localisation strategies.
Node.js does a good job of making this abstraction
available.
We just don't have that fully for all languages.
We're not taking advantage of that, and we're
certainly not taking advantage of it over
the JavaScript ecosystem.
JavaScript has localisation libraries that
will provide experience of textual strings
in a designated locale.
You can present it to the user in a in the
language that we're going to be able to understand.
So, we've talked about a lot of different
things so far.
There are a lot of steps that we can take
to including non-English speakers more in
JavaScript development.
Making tool chains for translating code to
other languages, like what we saw here with
koro, that's just one of them, and there is
more as well.
I don't have time to talk about the aspects
like documentation.
How do you translate documentation and how
do you make sure that that documentation stays
in sync between across languages?
How do you make things like mailing lists
or even meet-ups and conferences like this,
make those accessible to people who speak
any language, not just people who happen to
speak English?
I don't have time to go into the details today,
but I've spoken about some of the challenges
in the past, so, if you're interested, you
can check that out, or come and find me afterwards.
Of course, that means that not all the stuff
is technical, but - but some of his requires
you rolling up your sleeves and lying code,
and if someone is interesting in doing this
with JavaScript or another language like what
koro does for Go, go ahead and prove me wrong
when I say it can't be done in JavaScript.
But others are straightforward, and more low-tech.
They involve the ways we operate as a community.
We are scratching the surface here.
For think of this stuff to happen, we need
to commit ourselves to doing it.
We need to remember that 95 per cent of the
world doesn't speak English as their first
language, and 89 per cent of the world doesn't
speak English fluently at all.
Thanks to JavaScript's dominance over the
web over the years, that means that if there
is language that has been spoken and is being
written today by active users, and it is basically
a certainty that, at some point, that language
is being used alongside JavaScript, that JavaScript
is handling that language in some capacity.
That's a virtual certainty because of how
widely used JavaScript is across the web and
how powerful the web has been in transforming
people's lives, not just in English-speaking
countries, but really all around the world.
So, it means that there is really no language
that is as well suited and JavaScript is to
being used by the entire world, not just people
who speak English.
We have an opportunity to bridge this language
divide, to make Hopper's vision a reality
in a way that no other programming language
has been able to do before.
So, let's do that.
Let's make JavaScript a programming language
that is truly accessible to everyone, no matter
what language you happen to speak.
Thank you.
[Applause].